mon plus grand rêve aujourd'hui c'est
passer le reste de ma vie avec toi si on
leur a lancé vous verrez c'est à la
bonne franquette
mais c'est fait avec le coeur
comme si je n'étais pas là jusqu'à
holmes bergamote pour toi ma vague et
pour vous julien gingembre confit lee
mears ont fini à la chaux vous êtes seul
au monde m'ont dit que mon plus grand
rêve aujourd'hui c'est passer le reste
de ma vie avec toi
la famille je leur annonçais coup vote
aurait pu mettre en slip maman mieux
jugé que l'imitateur allez vous soyez se
renseigner quand je suis sûr qu'on a
plein de bon sens ping a perdu 6
secondes pas pour la dernière fois il
faut que t'arrêtes avait été calculée
bredou ce conte
c'est beau les gens fils ainsi pour
passer à table